the sweeping bay shimmering
mediterranean sea
red carpet and of course movie stars the
cannes film festival is back after a
one-year break because of the covid
pandemic
american director spike lee is the head
of the jury this year
as he arrived just before the cast of
the opening film annette
the excitement was palpable
annette is one of 24 films in
competition for the prestigious palm
door prize
the musical comedy by french american
director leo scarax stars marion cottier
and adam driver this is my favorite
festival ken i've always
before i came here looked at it as
you know a marker of great films the
festival's director says its return
is cause for celebration
in january and even february we had no
idea if the festival would be possible
because last year we had to cancel it
owing to the epidemic
so it's hugely satisfying to be back
it's such a pleasure and a relief
it's not only the movie industry and
fans that are delighted by the return
of cannes the festival attracts tens of
thousands of visitors
and after a very difficult year for the
tourism sector
there are many in the city that are very
happy to be back in business
a lack of tourists forced this luxury
hotel to close for six months last year
the manager says the festival will help
the local economy
it will present actually approximately
15 percent
of our yearly uh rooms revenue so
we do that in less than two weeks so
it's big
and also it brings a lot of positive
energy
for the city travel restrictions means
some film stars and visitors have stayed
away
for those attending special measures are
in place including
on-site covert testing nevertheless in
such
unusual and unpredictable times a
generous dose of glamour
and some captivating films certainly
offer
some welcome escapism natasha butler
al-jazeera
can